MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
to Talks of Google.
Today with us,
Stephon Alexander.
Following the great
minds that's first
drew links between music and
physics, "The Jazz of Physics,"
the book that Stephon
has in sales right now--
"The Jazz of Physics"
accompanies Stephon Alexander's
own tale from taking music
lessons as a boy in the Bronx
to studying theoretical
physics at Imperial College.
Covering the universe
from its birth
through its fate, its structure
on the smallest and largest
scales, the book
will inspire anyone
interested in the mysteries
of our universe, music,
and life itself.
Alexander is a physics
professor at Brown.
He did research here in
the neighborhood at SLAC
at Stanford.
He's the winner of the 2013
American Physical Society
Bouchet Award.
He's also a jazz musician
and recently recorded
his first electronic jazz
album with Erin Rioux.
Upcoming album with Grammy Award
winner Will Calhoun and Melvin
Gibbs will hit the
stores in a year.
So please join me in welcoming
Stephon Alexander to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHON ALEXANDER:
Well, I would like
to say it's a great
pleasure to be here.
It's actually a great
pleasure to be back.
I attended [INAUDIBLE]
twice in the past
and had given a previous Google
Talk of a different nature
a couple years ago.
Hopefully, this time
I won't be sweating.
I mean, I meant
that figuratively.
So anyway.
So let's begin with the talk.
So I want to first talk
about why I wrote the book.
I grew up in the
Bronx, New York.
My family immigrated
from the Caribbean,
from Trinidad to the Bronx.
And back in those days--
"back in those days"--
for Afro Caribbeans, a one
way to economic freedom was
to become a musician
or to play sports.
So it was in a mind
of my grandmother
for me to become
a concert pianist.
So I start off
with concert piano.
But I was more
interested-- I realized
I was an inquisitive
kid like many of us
who grew up to
become scientists.
We're just inquisitive
about the world around you.
And for me, I
wanted to understand
why was it that the music was
sounding interesting rather
than playing the music.
So it started at that age.
I started to realize that I
really didn't-- when I looked
at musicians around
me at that time,
in the '80s in the
Bronx where rap music,
hip-hop music was
being innovated,
I really didn't relate to the
way they were being personified
in the media, for example.
So I really didn't
fit in with that.
And this has to do
with identity now.
As I progressed along in high
school, De Witt Clinton High
School in the Bronx, I
discovered Mr. Kaplan,
who was my physics teacher.
And he was also a jazz musician,
a professional jazz musician.
And he was the one that
exposed me to physics.
And yet when I looked and
I saw what scientists--
I didn't really relate to that.
So throughout my
life and my career,
it's always been this kind
of dichotomy in a sense.
And my music and my physics
life were very much separate,
deliberately separate
from each other.
I used to play in clubs late
at night and during the daytime
the usual stuff, go and do
calculations as a post-doc.
And then some things
started to ignite
more of some sort of healthy
symbiosis between my physics
and my musical life.
And the book is a part of--
writing the book was part
of that reconciliation process.
So in a lot of ways,
this book is really also
a personal thing in the sense
that it's about that journey.
But it's also
about other things.
And that's kind of what I want
to talk about as well today.
So what are some
of the influences
that really influenced me as
I was growing up in the Bronx?
Well, there's this guy
Rakim who many people
deem to be the greatest
MC ever, period.
Now back in those
days, Rakim belonged
to a group of individuals who
called themselves the Five
Percenters.
And they believed in something
called supreme mathematics.
So you have these
guys in the Bronx
that were talking
about alien life forms
and coming up with their own
scientific theories about how
the world worked.
And Rakim was one of them.
But he dropped an album called
"Eric B. is President"--
I'm sorry, "My Melody."
And here's a quote from that.
"That's what I'm saying.
I drop science like a scientist.
My melody's in a code.
The very next episode has
a mic often distortin'
and ready to explode.
I keep the mic in Fahrenheit
freeze MC's to make them
colder.
The listeners' system
is kicking like solar."
So I remember as a 12-
or 13-year-old kid,
where science and the life
of the mind, in a sense,
was not what society was
telling us we should become,
and having the greatest MC
embracing scientific thought.
And that was something
that stuck in my mind.
So I thank Rakim for making
me feel like I belong
to something in this sense.
So that was one person.
The other person's
Albert Einstein.
I discovered Albert
Einstein when
I was eight years old in the
Museum of Natural History.
I got snuck off to the
side from the dinosaurs.
And I saw this
picture of this guy.
And I saw these equations.
And I thought this was
some kind of hidden code.
And I want to understand it.
And that's stuck to my
mind, Albert Einstein.
And then finally
one of the things
that also-- again,
we're looking at just
moments throughout my
life-- John Coltrane.
And one of the main
subjects of my talk today
will be this diagram.
This is a hand-drawn
diagram given-- gifted--
from John Coltrane to his
friend and mental partner--
they sort of theorized a lot
together, Dr. Yusef Lateef.
And he gave this to Yusef
Lateef as a birthday present.
And in 2005, I
actually had the honor
to speak to Yusef Lateef
about this diagram.
And this is one
of things that got
me thinking about what this
diagram has to do with physics.
And I'll get back
to tell you what
that has to do with physics.
But also what the
important thing
that one of the great heroes
and icons of jazz music,
and music in general,
John Coltrane,
is analyzing his music
through the lens of something
that he got from
Albert Einstein.
This is the book.
It's about uniting
science and music-- again,
because I'm not
doing anything new.
Again in the sense that-- I'll
get back to the "again" part--
but how did this really happen?
When did I really start
saying, OK, you know what?
I'm just going to bring the
physics and the music together.
It happened with
this individual.
How many people recognize
this individual?
the people down there?
There's Bono and David Bowie.
And that's Brian Eno.
And as Brian Eno,
as you know, he's
in the eyes of many
known to be the greatest
programmer of the DX7
frequency modulated synthesis.
So when I was a postdoc at
Imperial College in London,
it was a very
interesting time for me
because it was a time where,
as many of us who were postdocs
know that, you have to
do something interesting.
And I was, at the
time-- it was--
the name of the game
in the year 2000
was string theory and
early universe cosmology,
in this case cosmic inflation.
And my main thing there was
to try to bring them together.
So at the time I was
working on this project,
taking a risk in terms of
trying to put these two
things together, which I
was successful at doing,
by the way.
But at that time I was
kind of stress out.
And I was also considering
that I would actually
leave graduate-- quit physics
and maybe become a musician.
And I became friends
with Brian Eno.
That's a long story how I became
friends, but it's in the book.
And on my way to work, I
would stop by his studio
and hang out with him on the
order of four days a week
over a period of two years.
So we became-- he became
like a mentor of mine.
And one day I came
into his office.
And up to the left-hand
corner I saw, basically,
him playing on a
large computer screen
with these square figures.
And I thought that
he had lost it
because I thought he was playing
with virtual Lego or something
like that.
I kept coming in day after day.
And he started playing more
and more of this stuff.
And some point, he
stopped and told
me the idea at the time
of cellular automata
and the basic notion that
you have these simple rules
of your neighbors,
in this case, and you
can generate very
complex patterns
from very simple rules.
And that fit very nicely
with Brian's past work
in generative music and
one of his philosophies
towards composition
that you can read about
if you get various
books on Brian Eno
or look him up on YouTube.
And you're looking down
here at one of the pictures
that he can generate using
cellular automata out
of the millions of
pictures that can
occur from cellular automata.
And at that time, I
said, wait a minute.
This is interesting.
It finally congealed that
Brian is actually freely
importing ideas in a very
creative way from science
into his art and into his music
and doing a successful job,
but more importantly, not
really caring too much
about what others thought.
And I realized at
the time that really
what I was battling against
was that caring about what
other people thought and
also the fear of risk,
risk-taking in this case.
So I just decided
that I was going
to just-- if I was going
to go out of physics,
I was just going
to go out my way.
So then I started
really bringing together
my physics and my music world,
in particular, my jazz world,
together.
And so some of the ways
I would do that was I
would go to jazz clubs and
bring my physics papers with me
and do my calculations there.
And then interesting
things started happening.
In between playing sets, I would
come back and do a calculation.
But the most
interesting part was
talking to the jazz musicians.
I discovered that jazz
cats are basically
uber nerds themselves.
And that you start talking
about physics and the stuff
you're working on, they
find it very interesting
and they're like a
good sound board.
And they have their own ideas.
And that level of interaction,
even though they didn't really
know the physics I
was working on per se,
they always had something
interesting to tell me.
And that process of
opening up the conversation
and making my research world
inclusive to them really
helped me think differently
about my research.
Vice versa, I started to realize
that when I was hanging out
with-- doing research in my
physics colleagues, especially
people like Chris Isham-- I
don't know if you know Chris,
he's a very well-known
mathematical physicist--
that the way that we
were doing our research
was very similar to what
jazz musicians were doing.
It was that we were
just improvising
with equations and concepts.
We were taking
known things that we
had mastered-- differential
geometry, in Chris's case,
Topos theory.
And we were trying to create
something new with that known
stuff, just like jazz musicians
were using scales, melody,
harmony, rhythm all these things
and in real time spontaneously
creating something new.
So those two worlds
started to merge.
And now let me get a
little bit more concrete.
And now we're going to really
talk about some physics
and some music here.
And for the rest
of this talk, we'll
use-- you all know this already,
but since the world is looking,
I should say a few words here.
If I take a vibrating string.
And we're looking
up here at a string.
What can I point-- can I point
from something like this?
So if I look at the top
here, we see that that's
what we call the fundamental.
The string, basically, is
held up at two end points.
And it's oscillating
back and forth.
And that is what we call
the lowest frequency.
The second, if we divide
the string in half,
we find that the
string basically
has half the wavelength
of the fundamental.
We can divide the fundamental
into a third, its length,
and so on and so forth.
And so if I were to play
those things started in C,
the question is,
what would I get?
If I started with
the fundamental,
if I play C,
[MUSIC NOTE] if I go up,
if I double the frequency
or half the wavelength,
I get a high C, an octave.
[MUSIC NOTE] Any guess what I'll
get if I divide it by a third?
[MUSIC NOTES] I would get
the G, the perfect fifth.
If I did it by a quarter, I'll
get the F, a perfect fourth.
[MUSIC NOTES]
And, of course, the
perfect fifth and what
we call the fundamental,
the five to the one,
is a very powerful
chord progression.
So that's used a lot in many
Western classical jazz music.
And we'll get back to that.
And so we see a
direct connection
between the harmonics,
the so-called notion
that the idea that
the vibration of waves
could come together,
basically, to make sounds--
and not just pure tones, but
even more complicated tones.
So what does this have
to do with anything?
The premise of my
book is the following
in terms of the
physics and where
the physics meets the music.
I assert in my book
that after working
as a theoretical
physicist, looking
at things like quantum field
theory, string theory, even
loop quantum gravity, even
theories of that form,
that one of the
central core ideas,
regardless of what scale or
what domain of physical reality
we look at, the name of the
game is about vibration.
The name of the game is about
patterns of vibration, physics
of waves, if you like it.
I mean, I can't tell you
how many papers I've written
or my colleagues
have written over
last year at the end
of the day we're doing
some kind of Fourier transform.
So that's the central
idea from which now we
can start looking at
all these different ways
that jazz music, in
particular, quantum mechanics,
and cosmology are connected.
Again, I'm not, in this book,
saying that the universe is
a jazz improvisation.
It's a new way of talking
about physics, the same way
anyone that writes a popular
science book uses analogies,
uses metaphor to
talk about that.
Otherwise you just have
a full of equations.
I'm just using my knowledge
as a practicing musician
as a new way, a new lens to
draw parallels between music,
and hopefully ends up being a
fun and an enlightening read.
So let's talk about
one more idea which
is the Fourier idea, one of the
most important concepts in all
of physics and engineering.
And the basic idea is
that, at the end the day,
if we look at this very
complicated-looking wave,
the idea of the Fourier
wave uses the fact
that if I drop two
rocks in a pond,
I'll have two simple
waves emanating outwards.
And these waves at some
point will hit each other
and create another
wave pattern due
to either constructive or
destructive interference
of those waves.
So the fact that waves can add
up or subtract-- simple waves--
to give a more complicated
wave, the Fourier idea
is nothing but that idea.
So the idea here is
that I can add up
simple harmonic periodic
waves that we just
spoke about that
I can understand
purely in terms of integers.
The minute I specify
an integer, I
know something about the wave.
So I can think of waves, these
harmonic waves, as an alphabet.
Just like I have A, B, C, D,
I can think of these building
blocks as an
alphabet from which I
can combine to form complicated
sounds or complicated wave
patterns.
So in this case, this
complicated wave pattern
is sum of three of these,
three harmonic waves.
And it uses, basically, the idea
that waves that are in phase
can actually add up to
create bigger waves.
And winds that are out
of phase, you can cancel.
That's the basic physics.
And we use this to talk
about particle annihilation,
for example.
For the physicists [? in ?]
[? the ?] [? audience, ?] you
do a Fourier decomposition
of a mode expansion
of the creation-annihilation
operator.
It's basically
using the same idea,
electron-positron annihilation.
So this idea so powerful
that I can use it at
will throughout the book.
And it brings a lot
of things together.
So I said this book is about
connecting music and physics
again because I wish
someone would have told me
when I was a student who
was conflicted about being
a musician or being a physicist
or being a nobody-- whatever,
you know-- I wish that someone
would have told me that
at the very birth of what we
call a Western science, music
and astronomy and
mathematics and what became
physics were all unified.
And it begins actually
with Pythagoras,
who was the one that came up
with the Pythagorean scale
by basically looking at this
thing called a mono chord, one
string instrument
and actually moving
a bridge in these
integer relations
of the length of the string
and generating the scale.
And Pythagoras really
believed in this idea
of this harmony of the spheres.
And it was later on his students
like Plato and Aristotle
that sought to
geometrize this idea.
So when Kepler, our very
first astrophysicist,
came on the scene after 2,000
years of people being stuck--
the Ptolemaic models and
all these epicycles--
it was Kepler that really
at the end of the day
a physical cause for why
the planets were moving.
And he was stuck, as we recall.
He was stuck because of Mars.
Mars' orbit was so elliptical.
And he couldn't fit
in his Platonic model.
So he returned back to
the Pythagorean thinking,
after realizing that
Plato was a Pythagorean.
So then he started
assigning-- this
is own handwriting--
he started to assign
to the velocity-- here we're
looking at the sun and a planet
going around in an elliptic
orbit around the sun.
And what he did was to measure--
assigned a velocity closest
to the sun and furthest away
from the son of that planet.
And by assigning that
velocity to a note, the ratios
of those velocities, he was able
to come up with these scales.
And it's kind of interesting
that John Coltrane had an album
called "Interstellar Space."
And he has a song called "Mars."
If you actually study the
transcription of "Mars,"
you find that it has inklings
of this particular scale in it.
It's just a-- again,
it's a conjecture.
There's no proof in there.
But it's kind of interesting
that John Coltrane
wrote this album called
"Interstellar Space."
So then from that, he
was able to come up
with his three laws of
planetary motion, the first set
of equations, really,
that we started to assign
to astrophysical phenomenon.
This, of course,
then led Newton.
Newton was after
the one equation
that would replace this.
And that was kind of interesting
that musical thought was always
with us and, at some
point, bifurcated
into two separate
things that would then
encourage young
people like me to be
confused about where they fit.
So the lesson here is
for all the other people
out there watching this,
the music and the science
were never really
separate from day one.
So we should feel free to
play with both of them.
So another thing that
I do in the book book,
I also use music as an analogy
to understand a quantum world.
So I came up with a couple
of really neat analogies
that supposed to
sort of like evoke
a sense of even more wonder
in quantum mechanics,
but also to maybe clarify
some conceptual difficulties
that even I had as a researcher,
feeling so comfortable writing
the equations now of a
Feynman path integral
without really stepping
back to think of, OK,
what's going on
intuitively here?
So this analogy with jazz
improvisation kind of helped.
And I have to get some credit
to the great jazz saxophonist
Donald Harrison for
simultaneously come up
with this idea.
So the basic idea
is the following.
We look at something
like an electron, which
is a quantum particle.
Feynman taught us that
the electron does not
do what a macroscopic
object do, which
is that it traverses a very
deterministic and unique path
from the initial point
to the final point.
Instead it does something else.
And what it does
is really weird.
What it does,
according to Feynman,
is that it considers all
potential paths, this one
electron, from
point A to point B.
Now we would laugh at this and
say, well, this is ridiculous.
There's no way
this could happen.
But then there are very
precise experiments
that test the difference between
a particle going here and here.
One experiment's called
[INAUDIBLE] effect.
And when we study particle
interactions at the LHC,
there are many different paths
that particles could take.
And these things are measured
at a large Hadron collider
as well.
But there's another place
where, if this didn't happen,
there'd be no point for
Google to be interested.
It's called quantum computation,
the sum of the many paths.
It's just a formulation
of how qubits evolved.
I mean, that's just another
aspect, except in that case,
you're also looking at
entangled states as well.
But this whole idea
of superposition
in quantum mechanics
is really what's
given this weird notion
that the particles traverse
in all possible paths
between the beginning
point and the endpoint.
So that just is so
non-intuitive to me.
For all the years I've worked
on quantum mechanics and field
theory and stuff, I
just still don't get it.
So I have to get some kind
of other toehold on this.
And it came from Sonny
Rollins and Charlie Parker.
So what we're looking
at here is a line
that Sonny Rollins-- transcribed
lines that Sonny Rollins soloed
in improvisation.
And what we see here is that
there's a beginning note, which
is a D. And it ends
on a G. And as I said,
they're perfect fourths.
They're harmonically
related to each other.
So this idea in
jazz improvisation.
There are different strategies
that improvisers could employ.
And one strategy is
the idea of targeting.
So the idea of targeting is that
you know what beginning note
you're going to begin with.
And you have a sense
of the end note.
And what happens in between
are many possible paths
that could be taken.
Now this is happening
in real time.
So in real time, what note
Sonny Rollins plays here,
as opposed to some
other note, is
that he would consider all
possible notes at every step.
The previous note
does, of course,
inform what the
next note would be.
And that's also a quantum
mechanical thing, as well.
So the idea here is
that all possible notes
are being considered to traverse
how you get from the beginning
point to the end point.
And that captures,
in a sense, what's
happening with the
quantum particle, which
is that you're not necessarily
traversing literally all paths,
but all paths are
potential considerations
that is informed by
the previous notes,
but also informed
by the end point.
So I [INAUDIBLE] found to be
a very interesting analogy.
The book gets into it
in far more detail.
So I only have a half an
hour to talk about this.
And I have more
things to talk about.
The other thing I talk about,
the main thrust of my book,
though, it's a book
at the end of the day
about modern cosmology.
And it's a book about
structure formation.
One of the biggest
questions that we
ask as cosmologists is, how
did the large-scale structure
in the universe emerge?
And could the laws of
physics known to us,
or every bit of physics that we
know, from microscopic physics
to the gravitational
physics that we think we
know, could it account
for what we see?
So what we're looking at
here is a computer simulation
that matches large-scale
structured data of networks
of galaxies.
What we see here is five--
if you look at-- focus
in on this little box here--
500 million light years.
And as we continue to focus in,
we see clusters of galaxies.
And the question is, how
did 14 billion years ago,
before this network of
cosmic structure form,
how did a featureless universe
filled with radiation energy
develop into this?
And in my book, I go through
that this has to do with sound,
that this is now a picture of
the 14 billion years, the CMB
data of the tiny fluctuations
in the radiation of this plasma
in the early universe that
acted as primordial seeds that
grew into stars and galaxies,
that grew into the structure.
So the idea here
is to sort of take
the Pythagorean idea
of music of the spheres
and bring it into
this modern context.
Except the question is that the
music that we're going to get
is not necessarily
only harmonic.
It might look something
a little bit more
like jazz as an analogy.
And so, yes, we do know
that the correct physics
to understand that data
is a physics of solid.
So what we're looking
at here is hot regions
in this plasma and cold regions.
And you can think of this
plasma as a density, nothing
more than a density wave,
which is what a sound wave is.
And this sound wave actually
has a harmonic motion.
And those regions where we
have resonance, where we have,
basically, the most
energy in the wave,
are the ones that
develop eventually
whose energies energy collapse
gravitationally to form
the first stars.
So it's really a
sound phenomenon.
The universe did begin-- the
structure that we belong to,
this complicated network
of structure, literally
began with sound.
So then I started to
push this analogy further
in the book to think about
what is music if you really
think about what music is.
Well, there are many
different definitions.
And everyone has a
different-- every culture has
a different way of
thinking about music,
how music functions to them.
But one you could
think about music
is that people say
it's structured sound.
Well, if the
universe started off
as some sort of sound pattern
and developed into structure,
then I can then use this
analogy that, well, it's
a particular structure
of a sound phenomenon.
And it's kind of
interesting that people
like Bach and Ligeti,
composers like that,
played with fractal music.
They have self-similar
structures actually
in the music as it
unfolds in time.
And the distribution of galaxies
does have a self-similar type
of feel.
It's not really a fractal.
People did debate
that for a while.
But it does have a structure.
So in the book, I play
with that a little bit.
So we have a way
of making analogs
between quantum mechanics
and jazz improvisation.
We now talk about the
structured universe.
And, of course, we know that
our early universe is actually,
what?
Our early universe
is a quantum place.
One of the big questions
right now right up
the street, your friends
up the street at Stanford,
spend a lot of time
and energy thinking
into the quantum early universe
and how that universe basically
became classical.
And we believe it has something
to do with the phenomena called
cosmic inflation.
So now I can bring
together the quantum part
of the jazz of physics with
this classical part, which
is the structure formation.
And the question is
these initial sound
waves have to come
from something quantum.
And so I discuss
that in the book.
But I think the most
exciting part of my book
is not necessarily about
drawing analogies and talking
about known physics,
but I also use the book
as a device to say, can we
actually learn new things?
Can I actually use this analogy
to actually do new physics?
And so while writing the
book, as you will see,
I developed a new theory by
drawing this analogy further
and was able to publish a very
nice paper recently in "Physics
Letters B" based on this idea
with my colleague Marcelo
Gleiser and my grad
student Sam Cormack.
And this idea goes as following.
And then I'm done, too.
So let's go back
to this diagram.
This diagram, basically,
what it reveals is cycles.
Basically you see that
these clusters of notes--
I don't have time
to go into it--
but you see that what we
have is a 60-fold cycle.
The system, these notes, repeat
themselves every 60 times,
just like a clock repeats
itself every 12 times.
And Coltrane is
basically looking
at intervalic relationships
between very interesting scales
and how they fit
into this geometry.
Coltrane was a very big fan.
His biggest idol
was Albert Einstein.
And he got Einstein's
idea of invariance,
the idea of using
symmetry to understand
what remains invariant
if I change perspective.
In this case, the speed of
light remains invariant.
And to have that, you need a
four-dimensional space-time
structure that
related, basically,
length contraction
and time dilation
under these transformations.
Coltrane tried to do the
same thing in this diagram.
I don't have the
time to get into it,
but if you read the book,
I developed that fully.
But the important
thing there was
the idea of using these harmonic
cycles that Coltrane employed.
So, for example,
in "Giant Steps,"
you'll see he'll
have cycles that
go like-- [PLAYING SAXOPHONE]
and so on and so forth.
So the idea here is to try to
take this analogy of how a jazz
improviser might improvise.
So one thing that could
happen-- that happens
is that you have the
structure of the music.
Let's consider the 12-bar blues.
You have four beats
per bar, 12 bars.
And that harmonic structure
repeats itself in a cycle.
The rhythmic structure
also repeats itself.
And the improviser gets a
solo-- gets a chance every time
around this cycle to try
A different improvisation.
So one of the questions that
we were trying to understand
is the so-called how to
deal with the fine-tuning
of the coupling
constants in nature.
And one idea to resolve
this issue-- life depends.
We can't have carbon-based
life if carbon
weren't formed from stars.
And you can't have that if
the tuning of the forces
were within a few
percentage of each other,
if those ratios of those forces.
So what determines those forces,
the strength of those forces,
we don't know the
answer to that.
And one idea is that
there's a multiverse.
And many of you have
probably heard these talks.
What we came up with was
a different idea here,
using this idea of
jazz improvisation.
And the idea, again,
is that you have now--
and actually this
is the basic cycle.
It has to do with the sound
called a pentatonic scale--
if there's time.
And the basic idea
now is the following,
that instead of having a
multiverse-- like here,
different island universes that
are causally out of contact
with each other, you have
a universe that undergoes--
that is cyclic in a sense
that it expands, contracts
into a big bang, expands and
contracts, and just does that
indefinitely.
It does that indefinitely.
But every time it actually runs
into this so-called big bang,
the coupling constants of
nature of all the forces
undergo a quasi random walk.
It improvises.
And as you expand
out, it gets fixed.
And we just happened
to live in the epoch
where the coupling constants
evolve like a genetic code,
like a genetic
mutation, to actually
have the value that we have.
So what's really
cool about this?
We use this analogy from
music just like Kepler did.
But when we did the
equations, it worked bang on.
So I invite you to
read that paper.
You'll see it has-- of
course, there's the idea.
But the thing that
was remarkable
was when we actually looked at
the low-energy effective action
of the heterotic
string, the equation
just presented itself
so beautifully.
So again it just shows
that really embracing
this idea of musical
thought could
be very useful in research, in
my case in theoretical physics.
If you guys have
a second, I would
like to maybe play
something for you.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, sure.
STEPHON ALEXANDER: So as I
said, Coltrane's-- I want to do
a quick sort of physics
thing for you, which is,
as I told you, that in the
harmonics of the waves,
the most constant relationship,
aside from the octave,
is a perfect fifth.
And that happens purely from
the energetics of the wave.
So it's purely physical.
Any vibration I make
it, any vibration
will contain this
perfect fifth in it--
with a different amplitude, of
course, but it's still there.
So for example, if played
a D-- [MUSICAL NOTE]
and I don't move my
fingers-- [MUSICAL NOTE]
I get the A. That A is here.
[MUSICAL NOTE] So the perfect
fifth is contained in this D.
So you say, OK, so what?
So let me continue paying
sequences of perfect fifths.
[MUSICAL NOTES]
All right.
So I just played a
bunch of perfect fifths.
I'm going to reorganize
those perfect fifths
in ascending order, from
lowest note to highest note.
[MUSICAL NOTES]
That's a pentatonic scale.
Now one thing that's
interesting is that that scale's
been used in most cultures.
It's one scale.
But let me do some more things
are that pentatonic scale.
[MUSICAL NOTES]
That's a blues scale.
So the point here is that one
of the most used scales in all
of our-- is just
a sophistication,
a tiny sophistication over a
scale that's just generated
naturally from the
laws of physics,
just from the perfect
fifth relation.
And so it's no mistake
why "A Love Supreme," one
of Coltrane's greatest
works, is rooted
in this pentatonic scale.
So when Coltrane told David
Amram, the great composer,
that like Einstein, I am seeking
for something simple that
brings music together
from natural sources,
it couldn't be nothing
but this pentatonic scale.
All right.
So let me just see if I
can play something fun.
[PLAYING SAXOPHONE] Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
That was just made
up, by the way.
There's no copyright.
MALE SPEAKER: Since we're
at the cyclical universe,
what was the expansion?
The type Ia supernova?
STEPHON ALEXANDER:
The expansion of what?
AUDIENCE: The type Ia
supernovae results.
STEPHON ALEXANDER: Oh,
a dark energy, yes, yes.
So I had nothing or
very little to say
in my book about dark energy
because my book was really
focusing on the early universe,
the high energy universe.
But I did recently
publish a paper
with some colleagues about
dark energy about a month ago.
But it is not
related to the book.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, what's
special about physics in
terms of your analogies
and you're kind of parallel?
So you talk but jazz.
And jazz creates some structure.
Jazz lends itself
to multiple paths.
And I was thinking, well, you
could apply these analogies
and parallels to almost
anything, anything
in the world that has
structure, like biology.
Biology has-- you think of DNA
getting from a set of genes
and how they're randomly put
together to create structure,
and how plants
have cell symmetry.
And while you were in
the middle of your talk,
my brain just translated
physics to biology.
And so what is
special about physics
other you're a physicist?
STEPHON ALEXANDER:
To be honest, I
don't think there's anything
special about physics.
I think that what's
special about this
is that as a physicist
and someone that's
played around a lot
with music, I just
wanted to have those two
worlds speak to each other
and found lots of
interesting parallels.
But also, it helped
me do better research.
So I would encourage
biologists and other people
to start seriously-- the book
was a labor of love for me.
It's my first book, so
it took me quite a while
and a lot of
thought to write it.
And so it was a-- the byproduct,
the after-effects of it
is someone that now has a
little bit more integrative
knowledge of these two fields.
And so, maybe it was a
selfish thing for me.
So I think what was
special about it
for me was just the
act of writing the book
and finding these
new parallels that I
didn't know about it before.
But I think that
there's nothing special.
I think that in this
analogy-making game,
you can always find these
overlapping domains.
And then there's something
interesting there.
Because then where
they overlap and where
the analogies break down is
where something interesting
might flourish.
And in the book,
I talk about-- I
go into-- it's really also
a book, for me, about doing
research.
I mean, when I work with
my graduate students,
the question is, how do I enable
them to be better researchers?
Not to just learn
physics, but how
to do it, how to
write new papers,
how to come up with new ideas.
And this way of-- I realize
that all of my years
trying to be a jazz improviser
and playing spontaneously
on the spot with other
people and having them
support me, and function
with that group of people,
not being selfish--
all these things
are elements in
the research front
that I found to be
very useful with how
I interact with my colleagues,
how I interact with students.
I do think there's
something special.
But I also think that if
you do this analogy-making
with other fields, there'll be
something special and unique
there as well, too.
AUDIENCE: Could you
explain that Coltrane
diagram since you didn't
have time to get--
STEPHON ALEXANDER: OK, sure.
All right.
So there's the
Coltrane diagram again.
And going back to your thing--
so the diagram, I think,
was-- one interesting thing is
that a lot of jazz, not all,
are sort of trying to
do a similar thing.
They want to come up with
their own sort of system,
some kind of geometrical,
mathematical system,
because that enables them
to think more economically
about how to improvise.
Because, you know
there's many of thousands
of different scales.
You're playing.
What do you do?
So a lot of improvisers come
up with tricks of the trade.
So this diagram I claim
was some sort of thing
that Coltrane was trying
to systematize relationship
between scales and
harmonic relations
that was important to him.
So what you see here,
again, is a 60-sided cycle.
Now in terms of math,
there's something
called cyclical groups.
So the group Z12 is a
group, a [? mod ?] 12,
where you go around 12 times
and you come back to yourself.
So Z60 is our 60-fold cycle.
So if you really look closely,
you have 60 notes there.
And then what happens
there, you see,
you have clusters of those 60
notes, three clusters of notes.
If you actually start with
the C and you go around--
I can't point
out-- that actually
is a very important
scale that I think
[INAUDIBLE] or Schoenberg,
one of those people
who did group theory, applied
group theory to music.
That's now called all
intervalic tetrachord.
And there are two of them.
And that system exists
in this diagram.
The other thing that I'd also
say that's very important
here is that you have
the whole tone scale.
"Giant Steps" is basically
based on the augmented triad.
But you can actually make two
whole tone scales out of that.
And these are what we
call symmetric scales.
These are scales that
literally look symmetric
when you geometrize
them in terms
of these cycles, these
cyclical symmetries.
The other thing
that's important here
is something called a tritone,
which is a reflection.
If I reflect along C and
I come back down here,
I get the tritone.
And that maintains
itself in this diagram.
So it's not like a higher
dimensional version
of our 12-tone scale
that contains scalar
relationships in the geometry.
And you can now
ask yourself, you
can think about now
relativity theory.
And relativity
theory, as you know,
if I-- what special
relatively tells me
is that if I have
two observers moving
at some velocity with
respect to each other,
length will be contracted
for the fast-moving observer
relative to the observer
that's not moving.
And also time will
be dilated, meaning
so the rate at which a clock
will tick for that moving
observer will slow down
relative to the observer that's
not moving, relative to
that observer's clock.
So those things are
relative concepts.
Space and time intervals
are relative concepts
at the expense of
the speed of light
actually being the same in
both frames of reference.
So there's something
invariant about that geometry,
of those spatial,
temporal relationships.
There's something
invariant there,
which is the speed
of light, which
basically retains the length of
the four-dimensional geometry.
So the thing that's
actually invariant
is a four-dimensional
lengths measured
in the four-dimensional length.
So Coltrane tired to-- I
believe he read everything
he could get his hands
on about Einstein--
he was trying to find, OK, you
know these different scalar
relationships are kind
of relative to each other
in this geometry.
But the thing that's invariant
is the 60-fold cycle.
And that's the basic idea.
Now, of course, I in
the book go into-- I
try to develop the language so
that even if you know nothing
about music theory, by the time
you get to the end of the book,
you're like, OK, I
can use this language.
The other thing that's really
cool in this diagram-- and this
is a conjecture-- so "The New
York Times" review, basically,
tried to get at me.
I basically tried
to riff on this
because a lot of what goes
on, too, in theory-making
and also jazz music
is that we riff.
We make mistakes.
If I tell someone get up
here, get on my sax, and just
improvise, and if
you go in thinking
that you want to play something
perfect, you'll freeze up.
But if you go in, and
knowing that improvisation
is about making
mistakes, and learning
how to fall in real time,
then you could improvise.
So it's about when you play
that wrong note-- you will--
how like an acrobat you fall.
And that becomes
interesting improvisation.
So I riff on this.
And I said this
had this-- if you
look at this four-pointed
triangle, pentagram,
I started to say,
well, maybe this
led to this pentatonic scale,
this five-fold symmetry.
Now here's a puzzle that
I haven't figured out yet.
So maybe you guys can
help me with this.
The pentagram does have a--
in terms of group theory,
it has a five-fold symmetry.
If I perform discrete
transformations
on the edges of
this pentagram, it
remains invariant in
a five-fold manner.
That's pretty cool.
But if I start
coloring this diagram
with notes of the
pentatonic scale,
it's no longer invariant.
All right.
So the puzzle is, how
do I make it invariant?
I suspect that the
answer to that puzzle
reveals I think what Coltrane
didn't reveal to anybody else.
I think he left us as a
puzzle to Yusef Lateef.
Yusef Lateef was known to
be the guy of knowledge
to all the jazz musicians.
They used to get out to Detroit.
Coltrane and, I
think, Charles Mingus
and asked him theory questions.
So I think they had this
kind of relationship,
just like Einstein
and Godel had.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's thank
Stephon Alexander for--
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHON ALEXANDER: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.